There are two orthogonal problems that lead to a system crash. One is
power failure. The second is software failure,
or in other words, the application crashes
for some unknown reason, obviously a bug in the application. So Rio Vista poses
a very interesting rhetorical question. Suppose we
postulate that the only source of system
crash is software failure. There are bugs in
the software, and not power failure. How does
that change the design and implementation of failure
recovery? Now the question is how can we eliminate
power failure. Well, we can throw some hardware
at the problem and make power failure go away.
For example, we can get a UPS power supply and connect it to the portion of the
system that I want to be up even if the power fails. So the idea in
Rio Vista is, if we can take the memory and take a portion
of that main memory. And make that
persistent to power failures by adding a battery
backup. Then even if there's a power
failure, this portion of the memory, whatever changes,
you record it here. It's going to survive
that power failure because it has battery backed up.
That's the idea, if we can throw some
hardware at the problem and make the problem disappear.
So that we can then focus on how
to recover from failure, assuming that the only source
of failure is software crash. So with this
amendment. Will this make the implementation of transactions as
defined in LRVM cheap, so that designers will
actually use them? Let's see how this can help.